spoiler alerts but in case you didn't
know the fourth episode of Game of
Thrones final season was too stressing
in more ways than one viewers witnessed
two deaths a long-awaited romance scene
that was ruined just a few scenes later
and a moment of abandonment that broke a
million hearts suffice to say a Thrones
fans were known to happy with episode 4
and things might get even worse when
they realized why the episode was titled
the last of the Starks watching the
latest Game of Thrones instalments the
answer seems obvious the episode takes
its title from a line of dialogue Arya
Stark gives during a conversation with
Sansa bran and Jon we're family before
of us the last of the Starks easy
explanation right sure but pure Wow was
offered up a deeper significance to
arias words and to the title of episode
4 arias answer and Branagh to represent
the last living members of House Stark
that fans know of but Jon isn't
technically a stark there was mother was
Lyanna stark Jon belongs to House
Targaryen having taken the last name of
his father Rhaegar Targaryen and if Jon
has children according to the rules of
Westeros they too would be Targaryen
with John out of the count for the last
of the living Starks that leaves us with
just three true born children of Ned and
Catelyn Stark who have survived the
brutality of political warfare over the
course of the series some pretty big
issues arise here Brad has made it clear
on several occasions that not only is he
not really a stark anymore it's arguable
whether he's even still human and in
Episode four he reiterates this in a
conversation with Tyrion making it very
clear that you no longer considers
himself the stark air
I'm not Lord of Winterfell they're the
only surviving trueborn son of Ned Stark
you don't want it I don't really want
any more it seems unlikely at this point
that bran will ever produce an heir
after all he no longer wants anything
that leaves just our year and Sansa of
the last of the Starks but it also seems
highly unlikely the Arya will continue
the stark line either once it seemed
possible
I can be your family but in this episode
Aria showed just how much she has
changed gently but firmly rejecting
gendry's marriage proposal and any lady
would be lucky to have you
I'm not lady I never have been
Aria isn't about creating new life she
serves the god of death now and in
Episode four she strongly hinted that
our days as a stark and possibly her
days among the living were coming to an
end
King's Landing some unfinished business
wait here I don't plan on coming back
neither do I so could Sansa actually be
the last of the Starks she's already the
lady of Winterfell and that could remain
true as she might have children who bear
the stark name rather than her husband's
name yes children in Westeros usually
take their father's last name but there
are exceptions when it comes to noble
lines lady Lyanna Mormont for instance
inherited both her family name and title
from her mother lady make moment even if
Sansa were to die before having an heir
it's unlikely that the long and famous
stark line would be allowed to die out
after thousands of years of rule the
Starks of intermarried with and are
related to all the other major noble
families of the north most notably the
Karstarks and the embers of course both
of these lines were apparently ended
forever by the night Kings army but
there are no doubt other distant cousins
of stark blood who could take up the
wolf banner of Winterfell if needed and
it would be needed after all as Leanna
once famously said we know no king but
the king in the north whose name is
stark and that remains true even if the
last stark isn't a king at all but
rather a queen what if there's someone
else
someone better oh hey all the last of
the Starks check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]